all eukaryotic cells from yeast to those
that make up the human body contain
membrane bound organelles with
specialized functions mitochondria are
double membrane organelles that
harnessed most of the energy that cells
need to grow and reproduce nearly all of
this energy comes from reactions that
take place at the inner mitochondrial
membrane
one of the key roles of this membrane is
to act as a barrier to positively
charged particles called protons thus
allowing a concentration gradient to be
maintained where the inter membrane
space has far more protons than the
matrix
the membrane also contains a large
protein complex called f1 f0 ATP
synthase which uses the proton gradient
to drive the synthesis of ATP molecules
these ATP molecules ultimately provide
the energy for most of the cell's
reactions just as man-made power plants
produce electrical energy by using the
flow of wind water or steam to rotate a
turbine the synthase makes ATP by using
proton flow from one side of the inner
membrane to the other to rotate protein
subunits
if there is no proton gradient synthase
subunits stop rotating and the cell can
quickly become starved of energy and die
therefore the protein complexes and
small molecules that establish this
gradient and maintain it play an
essential role in the life of the cell
at the heart of this system are four
protein complexes numbered 1 through 4
complexes 1 3 & 4 directly pomme protons
from the matrix into the intermembrane
space
complex-2 does not directly pump protons
but it does promote proton pumping in
complexes 3 & 4 proton pumping requires
energy and the for protein complexes get
this energy by transferring electrons
through a series of coupled reactions
this linked process of electron
transport is why the 4 complexes are
collectively referred to as the electron
transport chain let's focus on complex 1
a byproduct of sugar metabolism called
NADH deposits to high-energy electrons
in complex one where they are passed
along a chain of redox centers redox
centers are clusters of atoms that have
different affinities for electrons based
on their unique atomic configurations
let's closely consider a pair of redox
centers to reveal two reasons why an
electron moves from the top redox center
to the bottom first the bottom redox
Center has higher affinity than the top
one second the distance between these
adjacent redox centers is ideal for an
electron jump to occur which explains
why electrons typically don't bypass the
bottom redox Center
a small amount of energy is released
each time an electron is passed between
redox centers complex one harnesses this
energy across all the redox centers and
uses it to pump protons
the last redox Center in complex one
donates two electrons to a coenzyme q
molecule complex 2 is similar to complex
one in two important ways first
high-energy electrons also enter complex
2 via a byproduct of sugar metabolism
although here the molecule is fadh2
second complex 2 also transfers
electrons between several redox centers
before donating them to coenzyme q one
major difference however is that complex
2 does not use the energy liberated to
pump protons coenzyme q molecules from
complexes 1 & 2 donate their electrons
to complex 3 one electron is recyclable
and can reenter complex 3 later but the
other passes through two redox centers
before reaching cytochrome C cytochrome
C carries the electron to complex for
the electron transport chain ends in
complex 4 where a series of reactions
involving 4 electrons converts a
molecule of oxygen to 2 molecules of
water the proton gradient is
strengthened because 4 protons from the
matrix are incorporated into water
molecules and another 4 are pumped into
the intermembrane space in the absence
of oxygen the electron transfer comes to
a halt
meaning that ATP synthesis also stops
indeed the reason we breathe oxygen is
so that it can serve as the final
electron acceptor at the end of the
electron transport chain
in this animation we have explored each
protein complex in isolation but in
reality they are very densely packed
together they effectively make the
entire surface of the inner
mitochondrial membrane
a giant cellular power plant
[Music]